a lot of people in our audience use
Craigslist just it's a fact of life so I
want to do something I thought you know
you don't have to applaud that so I
thought we'd help our audience members
make a sale or connection by showing
some of their craigslist ads right here
on the show that might help you you know
get some attention to your Craigslist ad
all right let's check out the first ad
right now by this person service offered
are you a butt-ugly dude for 200 bucks
I'll let you put my face on your tinder
profile I do it on the next yard sale
lots of odds and ends knickknacks
tchotchkes brick aback trinkets gimlets
dougas as well as a thesaurus the next
one for hire Sam Elliott stunt double
mustache elated stunts only
here we go once it romantic dinner for
two you provide the couple and the
romantic dinner I'll provide the mihrab
in your house while you eat here's one
Help Wanted guy who will play who watch
me play call of duty and giggle whenever
I say duty here's one help wanted
someone to tell me who the hell Kendrick
Lamar is and finally question is it a
beret or a loaf of sourdough bread it's
boats find out more at edible hats dot
young
I don't care what anyone says
you